I try to push you out of the circle try
last one in five seconds come on greenie
he's not coming back good enough cuz I
can keep going
brick by brick fella by dollar body by
body or you can call your boss and tell
him to shut down his operation tonight I
still don't understand what the doll has
to do with this suppose a demon demons
can sometimes use objects as conduits to
achieve their desired goal their desired
goal our souls John it's just
complicated just have very high
standards type a when I can make you
crazy if you're not like that
you seem pretty laid-back type B I'm
speaking of wit Jamie's blood type I
don't know I have to look up at the
house you don't know if she has friends
you don't know what she does all day and
you don't know your wife's blood type
sure y'all are married I may be its type
of where her folks New York yeah can
they get here in time for this press
conference tomorrow
wow I have no idea I haven't talked oh
you haven't called your wife's parents I
mean you can't get a signal in this
building I've been in here talking to
you well call them please